leute kennt ihr auch diesen moment ihr
seid auf irgendeiner party stellte auf
eine party ok und ihr lernt man zum
ersten mal kennt folgendermaßen du bist
du auf eine person zusätzlich so es geht
wohl gibt ebenso die hand und die andere
person schlägt mit der faust teilen ihr
beide denkt euch warum wurde ich geboren
und diese peinlichsten heute dreht sich
das heutige video dem stichwort aus den
und zwar wollte habe ich für euch eine
peinliche handshakes also eine queens
handshake fail compilation rausgesucht
die wir uns gemeinsam reinziehen werden
uns gemeinsam fragen werden warum
menschen überhaupt auf der welt
existieren entweder bereits heute ich
werde ich mich manchmal eine
schutzausrüstung
das könnte nämlich sein dass dem
heutigen video an einer anderen stelle
der gesichtsausdruck fällig wird
deswegen heute schutz zu suchen sind
[Musik]
also könnte was nicht sogar selbst die
hand geben das schlimmste bei sowas ist
leute das sind ja alles basketball
livespiele ok dh die kameras ich drauf
hunderttausende von menschen schauen
euch zu und ihr habt einfach den fehler
eures lebens herz eigentlich ganz gut
gesetzter das ist wirklich die einzige
art und weise mit so etwas umzugehen man
darf so was nicht unter den teppich
kehren leute auf gar keinen fall denn
dann wird es richtig peinlich wenn er so
weiter so genau drauf gucken ob ihre
hände und dann versuchen das über den
teppich zu kehren
man muss sollte ich habe langjährige
erfahrungen in der bewältigung von
peinlichen handshakes okay dann muss es
ansprechen man muss ansprechend ein witz
zu machen
so zum beispiel wie alle star den
anschlag habe ich noch nie gesehen oder
verpiss dich du spaß
[Musik]
leute das geht nicht ich brauche ich
noch eine zweite sind vor allem visa
luca dem auto vor ihr seid profi
basketballspieler und das passiert wenn
die live im fernsehen sei das überhaupt
[Musik]
wo alters auch hart ist das einfach
nicht wenn vielleicht die von euch
dieses was wird passieren oder so der
typ ist leitet kassel basketballspieler
und die sache ist natürlich wenn man ein
gewisses level in seinem sport erreicht
hat kann man komplett auf alle anderen
mitmenschen scheißen so steht es im
deutschen grundgesetz artikel 131 selber
nachlesen dasteht wenn du erfolgreicher
sportler bist so scheiße auf sein
komplettes umfeld und schlagt niemals
eindeutig natürliche cam ist ihr könnt
ihr selbst eigentlich eine hand von der
einen seite kommt und die andere von der
anderen sie können sich erreichen
[Musik]
und dann hat euch wahrscheinlich auch
gesagt im moment oder das ist richtig
ort ist so eine preisverleihung
[Musik]
hat er hier sehen wie ist der versuch es
zu retten als wahrscheinlich oder leute
scheiß auf meine tipps mal spricht auf
jeden fall nicht an macht einen witz
darüber sondern wenn ihr die hand
ausgestreckt und jemand einschlägt den
einfach eure zweiter hand dazu sind eure
die hochfranken und guckt euch dabei
aber einfach mit zum todes blick einfach
um das macht ihr dann drei minuten lang
dann ist nicht öffentlich
[Musik]
wenn man sein gesicht hat sich was die
hofft software war das lebron james und
wir wollen wir einen klecks steckte ein
während langsam realisiert so margreiter
wissen viele nicht aber das ist manchmal
schwer das ist ja mal nachdem dieser
handshake mit lebron projekt wurde hat
er sich entschieden er kann dieser
sprache einfach nicht umgehen da muss
jetzt irgendwas ganz verrücktes
abgespecktes machen um damit umgehen zu
können ist natürlich ein youtuber
geworden eiskalt alter als ob er denn
gemacht hatte galt das war wird
absichtlich es war nicht als junge lebt
einfach den handshake weg und also so du
[ __ ] und er lacht nur
aber wer ist feiert als er diese typen
kommen teilweise so arrogant rüber dabei
vielleicht was auch immer sofort wird
sich höchstwahrscheinlich auch machen
heuer schon mal vor so live live tv alle
kameras auf dich und du gehst du hin bei
den check-in auch die hand raus du
selbst einfach auf den härter drauf
hatte können die richtige musik bitte
für den web die klassische musik 32
das übrigens die einzige sache für
dibaba wagen gut ist
[Musik]
ohropax safe alter ist auch wenn ihr
eure faust dahin leitet und das sieht so
aus als wollte er war jemand einschlagen
aber er wollte gar nicht einschlagen
sondern die bereitet einfach gerade vor
dass ihr mit eurer eigenen geballten
faust europa greift kann es auch okay
also das soll soweit mal gewesen sein
ich habe heute noch einen sehr
beschäftigen tag muss noch sechs stunden
nach düsseldorf waren dann wieder neue
folge was geht rät deswegen heute ein
kleines reaction video
ich hoffe ihr habt eure sonnenbrillen
aufgehabt vielen einflüssen charlotte
kalabrien und hier geht es zu einer
neuen folge von was das geht und
multimedia da komme ich nicht mehr
folgen kann abschätzen denn wir machen
leute sachen